Et c'est pire quand les médicaments
ne marchent pas et provoquent des effets secondaires.
Prenons l'aspirine -- une personne sur quatre
prenant de l'aspirine pour réduire le risque de maladie cardiovasculaire
est résistante à l'aspirine.
Et elle a les mêmes risques d'hémorragie gastro-intestinale
qui tue des milliers de gens chaque année.
Ces effets indésirables sont, d'après certaines estimations,
la quatrième cause principale de mortalité aux États-Unis.
Mon propre grand-père est mort après qu'une seule dose d'antibiotique
ait causé une insuffisance rénale.
Les effets indésirables des médicaments et les effets secondaires
sont souvent liés aux défis du dosage.
Je suis formé en pédiatrie, les petits, et en médecine interne, les grands,
et une nuit, je peux être de garde à l'USIN,
dosant prudemment au milligramme près
un médicament pour un bébé.
La nuit suivante -- de garde aux urgences,
traitant un patient costaud de 180 kg ou un patient âgé et fragile,
qui, pour la plupart, doivent recevoir la même dose de médicaments
d'après le formulaire.
Ce qui signifie que, la plupart du temps, je sous-dose le rugbyman,
et je surdose le patient de maison de retraite.
Au-delà du poids et de l'âge,
nous négligeons les différences raciales et sexuelles dans le dosage.
En plus de ça, nous savons que nous avons un défi majeur
avec la non-conformité et le respect faible.
Certains doivent suivre un traitement
et ne le suivent pas, ou le suivent de façon erronée.
Voyez-vous, 40% des Américains de plus de 65 ans
ont cinq ordonnances médicales ou plus.
Parfois 15 ou plus.
Même de légers progrès dans le respect du traitement
peuvent drastiquement économiser de l'argent et sauver des vies.
Donc, en pensant au futur,
vous pensez que là où nous sommes maintenant,
nous entendons parler de traitements connectés, personnalisés, ciblés,
d'Internet des objets, de thérapie génique, d'IA,
nous sommes déjà dans l'ère de la médecine de précision.
Mais nous vivons encore dans une ère
de médecine à tâtonnements, empirique et imprécise.
Nous pouvons faire mieux.
Et si nous imaginions des façons de faciliter la prise de vos médicaments ?
D'obtenir les bonnes doses et combinaisons qui vous correspondent ?
Et si nous pouvions dépasser la technologie de pointe actuelle
que sont les coupe-pilules et les fax,
pour une ère de meilleurs résultats, de coûts plus bas,
sauvant des vies et de la place dans vos armoires à pharmacie ?
Une part de la solution est dans les façons émergentes
de mesurer et connecter nos données médicales.
Nous vivons dans un monde réactif, qui soigne les maladies,
où l'information stockée ne circule pas.
Nous avons le pouvoir de passer à un monde de soins médicaux
plus continu, plus rapide, plus préventif.
Cela commence en partie avec le monde émergent du soi quantifié,
nous pouvons mesurer tellement de nos physiologies et comportements ;
ça reste souvent dans le téléphone et la balance,
mais ça se connecte peu à peu à nos médecins et soignants
pour mieux optimiser la prévention, les diagnostics et le traitement.
Et cela nous amène à faire des choses intéressantes.
Prenons l'hypertension, par exemple.
C'est le premier facteur mondial du risque de mort précoce et de morbidité.
Environ la moitié des Américains adultes font de l'hypertension,
moins de la moitié est bien suivie.
Souvent car ça demande deux ou trois sortes de médicaments différents,
car c'est dur de respecter et d'ajuster les doses de médicaments.
Nous avons 500 morts prévisibles dues à une hypertension non suivie
chaque jour aux États-Unis.
Nous sommes maintenant dans l'ère des tensiomètres connectés --
les autorités ont approuvé un brassard
qui tient dans votre montre.
Il existe désormais des prototypes de tensiomètres connectés sans brassard
qui peuvent mesurer votre tension en continu.
Plus tard, je pourrais...
Au lieu de vérifier ma tension à la clinique,
mon médecin pourrait voir en temps réel mes chiffres et tendances
et les ajuster en fonction,
avec l'aide d'un algorithme de dosage de la tension,
ou en utilisant l'Internet des objets.
La technologie aujourd'hui peut faire encore plus.
Ma montre intelligente a déjà un ECG intégré,
qui peut être lu par l'intelligence artificielle.
Je porte un petit patch, de la taille d'un pansement,
qui diffuse en direct mes signes vitaux.
Regardons.
Il y a de quoi s'inquiéter en ce moment.
(Rires)
Ce ne sont pas juste mes signes vitaux en temps réel
que mon équipe médicale et moi pouvons voir,
également mes données rétrospectives,
encore une fois, pourraient être utilisées pour modifier la dose et les médicaments.
Même mon poids peut être super-quantifié.
Mon poids, ma morphologie, ma masse corporelle, ma graisse,
ma masse musculaire,
peuvent être utilisés pour optimiser ma prévention ou mon traitement.
Ce n'est pas que pour les technophiles.
Les ingénieurs du MIT ont modifié le Wi-Fi
pour pouvoir nous connecter et recueillir facilement nos signes vitaux,
de nos bagues connectées ou nos matelas intelligents,
nous pouvons partager ce double numérique
et potentiellement le crowdsourcer, partageant nos informations de santé,
comme avec Google Maps et notre conduite,
pour améliorer, non pas notre conduite, mais notre expérience santé globalement.
Donc, c'est génial.
Nous pouvons recueillir ces informations.
Et si vos examens médicaux pouvaient passer du labo central
à votre maison, votre téléphone et même notre corps
pour mesurer les niveaux de médicament et autres ?
Nous sommes dans l'ère de la génomique.
J'ai été séquencé, ça coûte moins de 1 000 dollars.
Je comprends ma pharmacogénomique -- comment mes gènes influencent
le besoin d'une dose haute, basse ou peut-être un médicament différent.
Imaginez si votre médecin ou pharmacien
avait cette information intégrée à son processus,
augmentée par l'intelligence artificielle, IA ou comme je l'appelle, AA,
l'intelligence augmentée, pour l'exploiter,
pour comprendre parmi les plus de18 000 médicaments approuvés
quelles seraient la bonne dose et combinaison pour vous.
Super, nous pouvons peut-être optimiser vos médicaments et doses,
mais le problème est l'utilisation de cette incroyable technologie
pour garder une trace de nos médicaments.
Et bien sûr, ces technologies évoluent, des distributeurs connectés,
des applis de rappel, des capsules de flacons de pilules intelligentes
vous envoient un SMS, tweetent votre mère
si vous n'avez pas pris vos médicaments.
Amazon vient d'acquérir PillPack,
bientôt nos médicaments seront livrés le jour même par un drone.
Donc, tout cela est possible aujourd'hui,
mais nous prenons encore beaucoup de comprimés.
Et si nous simplifions ?
Une des solutions est de mieux utiliser la polypilule.
Une polypilule comprend plusieurs médicaments dans un seul comprimé.
Les remèdes contre la grippe et le rhume existent déjà en vente libre.
Des études de prévention de la polypilule existent
et donnent des combinaisons de statines, tension, aspirine,
qui, dans des études randomisées, ont montré
la forte réduction du risque par rapport au placebo.
Mais ces polypilules n'étaient pas personnalisées, optimisées.
Et si vous pouviez optimiser votre propre polypilule ?
Elle serait créée pour vous, en fonction de vous, elle s'adapterait au quotidien.
Nous sommes dans l'ère de l'impression 3D, vous pouvez imprimer
vos propres appareils dentaires, auditifs, orthopédiques,
j'ai même été scanné et mes jeans sont taillés pour moi.
Donc, j'ai réfléchi,
si on pouvait imprimer en 3D votre propre polypilule ?
Donc, au lieu de six médicaments, par exemple,
je les combinerais en un seul.
Plus facile à prendre, plus facile à respecter
et potentiellement, ça pourrait intégrer des suppléments,
comme de la vitamine D ou du CoQ10.
Avec un peu d'aide -- j'appelle ça « IntelliMeds » --
et l'aide de mon équipe d'ingénierie IntelliMedicine,
nous avons créé le premier prototype d'imprimante de l'IntelliMedicine.
Voilà comment ça fonctionne :
au lieu de tablettes entières, des micro médicaments,
un ou deux milligrammes chacun, triés et sélectionnés en fonction
de la dose et de la combinaison nécessaires à un individu.
Ce seraient des doses et combinaisons à prendre en même temps,
des médicaments approuvés par les autorités.
Nous pourrions changer la pharmacocinétique
en superposant professionnellement différents éléments
aux micro-médicaments individuels.
Et quand on appuie sur imprimer,
vous imprimez votre combinaison de médicaments qui vous est propre
chaque jour.
Nous commencerions avec
les médicaments génériques pour les cas les plus communs.
Environ 90% des médicaments prescrits sont des génériques à bas coût.
Une fois que les pilules sont imprimées, nous pouvons ajouter des options.
Nous pourrions imprimer le nom du patient,
la date, le jour de la semaine, un code QR.
Nous pourrions imprimer des médicaments
pour diminuer les doses d'un patient réduisant les stéroïdes
ou les médicaments contre la douleur.
Donc, nous vous montrons le prototype de l'imprimante IntelliMedicine.
Révélée ici-même.
Elle a 16 silos différents,
contenant chacun des micro-médicaments individuels.
Et je peux à présent ajuster sur le logiciel le dosage individuel.
Quand je fais cela, le bras robotisé va ajuster
la hauteur de ces capsules et les micro-médicaments vont être libérés.
Je peux maintenant --
le processus automatisé tournerait
et s'assurerait qu'ils sont chargés.
Quand je clique sur imprimer,
tout va passer dans l'appareil,
je peux alors attraper ma polypilule personnalisée imprimée,
avec les doses et les médicaments faits pour moi.
Nous pouvons regarder, en repassant les slides,
vous pouvez voir tout le processus, nous pouvons voir les silos choisis,
les pilules passant dans les différents silos
et assemblées en capsule individuelle.
C'est génial,
je peux imprimer mes propres médicaments, au lieu de prendre six pilules.
Je peux regarder mes doses individuelles,
ma montre intelligente vérifie ma tension,
j'avais besoin d'ajuster mes médicaments pour la tension,
mon niveau de coumaphène, mon sang est trop liquide,
donc je réduis la dose de coumaphène, un anticoagulant, de mon micro-médicament.
Ça peut être adapté au quotidien,
programmé par mon médecin ou mon cardiologue.
Vous pouvez imaginer qu'une imprimante plus grande, plus rapide
pourrait se trouver dans votre pharmacie,
chez votre médecin, dans un hôpital de campagne.
Mais elle pourrait devenir plus petite et se retrouver chez vous,
avec des cartouches intégrées, comme ça, livrées par drone.
Elle pourrait imprimer vos polypilules personnalisées,
chaque matin, dans votre cuisine ou votre salle de bains.
Je pense que ça pourrait évoluer vers une façon incroyable d'améliorer
l'adhésion médicamenteuse à travers le monde.
J'espère que nous pouvons réimaginer le futur de la médecine de façon nouvelle,
de la polypharmacie,
le générique pour tous, une adhésion faible, des complications
à une ère du médicament personnalisé, précis, à la demande,
qui nous permet d'individualiser notre propre santé
et la santé et la médecine dans le monde.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)
Animatrice : Daniel, c'est super.
Vraiment génial.
Une question, cependant.
Dans combien de temps
les patients des maisons de retraite, dont vous avez parlé,
pourront imprimer leurs pilules de chez eux ?
Daniel Kraft : Encore une fois, ce n'est qu'un prototype.
surtout dans les maisons de retraite où les gens prennent plusieurs médicaments
et les mélangent souvent,
donc ce serait l'endroit idéal pour débuter avec ces technologies.
Ça ne commencera pas dans votre salle de bains.
Nous devons déployer ces choses de façon intelligente,
tout en réalisant qu'il y a de nombreux défis
de dosage, d'adhésion, de précision
et avec toutes ces nouvelles technologies que nous pouvons intégrer et exploiter,
nous avons besoin de telles approches pour vraiment catalyser et favoriser
un vrai futur de la santé et de la médecine.
Animateur : Super. Merci. DK : Merci.
(Applaudissements)